the
[Music]
prevailing
sexual ethic that is that is reigning in
the country and being enforced by the
state is insane in wisconsin right now
is a wisconsin school district that just
filed a title ix
sexual harassment complained
against middle school students and they
they are filing this complaint against
the students
because the students
used the correct pronoun to refer to one
of their classmates
an investigation into three keel middle
school students has been launched the
school district has filed a title ix
complaint accusing the students of using
incorrect pronouns while addressing
another student fox 11's monique lopez
spoke with the parent of one of the
students in this project education
report
i received a phone call from the
principal over at the elementary school
for warning me letting me know that i
was going to be receiving an email
with sexual harassment allegations
against my son rosemary rabidu's 13 year
old son braden is one of the three 8th
grade kiel middle school students
accused of sexual harassment something
she disputes he said he's being
allegedly charged with sexual harassment
for not using proper pronouns some might
say or think that you or your son are
against the lgbtq plus community not at
all not at all
there's so much here you could write a
doctoral dissertation about this whole
interview
because
you saw right there at the end the
interviewer says so your 13 year old son
is being charged with sexual harassment
for using the correct pronouns to refer
to a sexually confused classmate
some people would say you're against the
lgbtq community and you see what that
woman says this totally normal mother
who says are you kidding you're accusing
my 13 year old son of sexual harassment
for calling a her a her or a him a him
and they said but are you against the
lgbt she said no no we're for lgbt we
love we're totally pro-lgbt oh yeah man
absolutely that's our we worship at the
altar of lgbt because this woman knows
that that's part of the public religion
and she knows that if you contradict the
public religion
you will be called a heretic and you
will be ostracized and you will be
punished
and she knows that so even this woman
who's defending her kid and saying what
you're telling me my 13 year old son has
to use the wrong pronouns to apparently
this one of the students wants the
pronoun to be they or them
which which makes me wonder if the
student has multiple personality
disorder that they think that they have
multiple people inside of them that they
and them which is now being used as a
singular pronoun by very confused people
and the student said i'm not going to do
that and now the student's being
punished are you against the lgbt no no
never never no please
now of course if one is a christian
a jew
a muslim
an agnostic person who just sort of
holds on to a traditional sexual ethic
they might
have objections to some
aspects of the lgbt lmnop
ideology and sexual ethic
they
for all of the history
of civilization pretty much their people
would have had legitimate objections to
some of that sexual ethic you are not
permitted to have those objections now
and we're we're being told this is in
the name of neutrality and
open-mindedness and liberality and but
of course it's not
really what the
state has said here is no you do not
have the right to your religion you do
not have the right to your sexual ethic
you do not have the right to think what
you think
actually it's the most closed-minded
sort of
sort of
regime that one could possibly imagine
and now it's being taken to the height
of absurdity charge then of course
they're going after the 13 year old boys
which is preposterous on the schoolyard
people say all sorts of mean things but
the kids aren't even saying a mean thing
here they're being punished not for
telling a lie not for being insulting
not for being cruel they're being
punished for telling the truth and
people around the country are looking at
this and they're saying hey whatever it
is
whatever the left is selling we are not
buying if this is what leftism leads to
we're out see you later folks right now
go to bowlingbranch.com use promo code
michael bowlin branch not only helps me
sleep better but it also teaches me
things did you know
did you know that thread count is just a
totally made-up number
it's not that it's a made-up number but
it's a it's a made-up
meaningful statement you always hear
sheet companies they say we've got a
seven gazillion thread count it doesn't
matter how many threads you've got if
the threads are not of the highest
quality okay so a lot of a lot of sheet
companies they'll say oh you've got all
this thread count but their sheets
aren't aren't any good because the
threads are the threads aren't very high
quality bowl and branch uses only the
best 100 organic cotton threads on earth
for a superior softness and a better
night's sleep i love these guys i've
been sleeping on bowling brains for
years they're like a drug dealer they
gave me the first first batch for free
and now i've been buying them ever since
three u.s presidents sleep on bowling
branch three us presidents and one of
your favorite podcast hosts check it out
right now you get 15
off your first set of sheets when you
visit bowlingbranch.com use promo code
michael that's b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com use promo code michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
the libs are losing right now they're at
least losing round with the people
because we can see what they're doing we
can see what they're doing in the
schools that was first opened to us
during covid19 during the lockdowns
where parents could see on a screen what
their kids were being taught that's
because of social media which though
social media tries to suppress some
awful clips of the libs they don't often
totally succeed at that is because we're
seeing what they're euphemistic abstract
policies choice and affirmation and
we're seeing what that means in real
life there's a video brought to us by
our great friends over at libs of tick
tock of a
queer surgeon that's his his
name on
twitter at queer surgeon this guy blair
peters bragging about performing quote
gender affirming mastectomies top
surgeries for three young adults and
adolescents in a day sometimes and by
that he means lopping off the perfectly
healthy breasts of teenage girls of
these young girls he brags about it on
video
i'm here to clarify and speak some
truths about what's happening with
gender affirming care and adolescence
most of the bills that are going through
right now aim to limit this care for
people under the age of 18. and there's
this false narrative that a lot of
teenagers are having gender affirming
surgery most of the teenagers that are
having surgery are getting chest surgery
and most of that is happening before 18
because these individuals didn't have
access to early enough medical treatment
so
using surgery as sort of this false
narrative to attack gender affirming
care as a whole is not correct the truth
is that by limiting access to medical
care with some of these bills you're
actually going to cause more people to
need gender affirming surgical care
that's his explanation he's saying look
so the reason that i'm lopping off the
perfectly healthy sexual organs of
teenage girls left and right in medical
experiments the likes of which we've
never seen before in the world we're
doing this because they're not letting
us pump five-year-olds full of hormones
and and eight-year-olds full of
cross-sex hormones and puberty blockers
so if they would just let us do that
then i wouldn't have to lop off the
perfectly healthy organs of the
teenagers okay and that's why it's so
important for us to to pass these laws
that will that will uh ensure our right
to to sexually mutilate little kids
that's what he's saying in a just
society this guy would be in prison okay
his name is his name blair peters
in a just society this man would not be
practicing medicine he would not be
bragging about he he posted this video
it's not it wasn't some undercover
investigation he himself posted this
video to tick tock which none of us
would have seen because tick-tock is all
young people and obviously skews to the
left and then lives of tiktok reposts it
to twitter and we get to see it this guy
should be in prison there should be laws
against the sort of thing that he is
doing
and obviously there should be laws
against the sort of thing that he is
advocating which is even more radical
and there's no throw your hands up in
the air guys there's no bury your head
in the sand there's no you do you i'm
not going to force my views on you
either we're going to live in a country
that sexually mutilates little kids or
not the law is going to say one thing or
the other either we're allowed to do
that or we're not allowed to do that i
think we should not be allowed to do
that i think it's wrong i think it's
wrong because of biology and because of
philosophy and because of morality and i
think it's wrong in part because we just
all know it's wrong and even people who
are not the most educated or
sophisticated or read the latest
journals we just know it's wrong to do
that to rot lop the breasts off of
teenage girls it's just wrong right and
we know it and we're right to know that
and we don't need to second-guess that
and we don't need to try to deny the
intuitions that are happen to be correct
and we have the right in a
self-government
if the if indeed we live in a
self-government to pass laws against
that and to criminalize this and if this
creep if this pervert blair peters
decides to keep pushing this radical
destructive sexual ideology on innocent
little kids then that guy should go to
jail and there's nothing wrong with that
okay
i'm so glad you like that clip now ring
that smash that like that click and make
sure is that i say that right i think i
did make sure that you get the
notifications for the michael knowles
show you can also go to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play wherever
you get your audio podcast subscribe to
the michael noll show leave a five star
review leave 10 star revenue if you
wouldn't mind we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]